so the new gta game is iron and it's not
what everyone wanted the new gta 6 no
it's gta the definite edition the san
andreas from cj from grow
yeah
it's a remake it's another remake but
the thing about it it's not just any
remake it's a terrible dodge
and it's becoming very quickly one of
the lowest rated games on metacritic
with a impressive score of 0.7 well done
grand theft auto
why are all big game companies going to
they're all bad now is there anyone left
stop ahead
watch metacritic remove remove user
score because they're toxic and evil and
bullying that's the next step we're
getting targeted by evil dislikes we're
gonna follow youtube's idea and remove
it so am i gonna play the game
absolutely not but we are gonna laugh at
how just bad it is five has graciously
compiled for me some of the finest clips
just showing how good this game is let's
check it out
i don't even know what to look at first
first of all it's important to do your
exercises a lot of people skip next day
it's becoming the new leg day and i
appreciate that uh dta
definite edition understands what is
wrong with their face why does the game
look old there i thought remakes were
supposed to make them look good right
they looked worse how's that even
possible okay so
[Laughter]
i don't even know which way it takes me
a second to understand which one is
which holy [ __ ] this is awesome so the
top one is the original one the bottom
one is the remake oh my god they look
like those you know the game that was
made by one person part time
it looks like hard time dude did they
hire this guy to just remake your entire
series
gta what the heck rockstar oh my god you
cannot tell me they look identical look
at their faces look at their faces look
at the face oh this guy
no
the original looks more detailed why
would they do that oh
how is this
how
oh man oh this is so good god bless you
so much
at least all of them
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait
those arms dude one of the main
characters you know no big deal well i
that here's definitely why to get the
definite edition
i've never seen a more compelling reason
why you shouldn't dish out what is it 60
for a brand new game a brand new game
that's been out for 15 years and you can
probably play for free at this point
shouldn't that be a rule i don't know
man what
oh
oh that is
bad
that is baffling they really put their
heart and soul into this all alright
here we go let's watch
let's go
yeah boy
[Music]
nice
invisible bridges they just never stop
appearing they cannot be trusted he's
like cyberpunk all over again it doesn't
matter what game you're selling it's
what hype you're selling you think these
big companies would learn at at some
point like these giant game studios
would understand you know we see all
these other our competitors messing up
all their releases and giving out
dishing out poor quality products you
know maybe we should like
i thought rockstar was above it but
maybe i don't follow it out
bruh god who wouldn't want to look at
that face a face only a mother can truly
love how old is san andreas that was
like the one gta game everyone played
not that get out of here the rock they
also already released it on google play
so it's like all right 2004 dude damn i
remember me my boy
we fired up that playstation 2
oh
that was the days man
oh that was the best do this
fast forward today's garbage
this feels like the soul and soulless
meme
right like i would much rather the only
improvement is that a higher frame rate
sure all right [ __ ] your sixty dollars
for a better frame rate oh yeah okay
cool you [ __ ] it all up oh that is
just sad this is just sad to look at
babe i got a ton of videos look all my
paper man left me with number small
change
hey get yourself a beer so
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's go
this is literally
cyberpunk oh gosh
i remember when cyberpunk first came out
everyone was like no people are just
cherry-picking bad clips it's like have
you played the game you cannot avoid any
bugs it's baffling how they allow this
nice that's how i drive as well
how does that even happen man
[Laughter]
he saw me
all right what else we got
never go off-roading these games
they're not built for it
oh oh
okay
oh that's so good it's so funny how i
couldn't even tell the difference like i
thought the first game was a remake oh
man the pharmaceutical scientist is
going to get you pogo
here you go pogo have a gold coin good
thing pogo has a banana cannon those
nasty scientists deserve to die now get
the shampoo
it happens to me it happens to everyone
everyone runs into cars usually there's
a car running into you that kills you
but no it's basically the opposite it's
you running into the car
oh my god how much can he clip through
everything i'm gonna be a hygiene
technician coming up in the world huh
just a stepping
whoever played this is a bad player
obviously he should be prepared that
cars teleport randomly into nowhere
what a fool
this is the salty gamers toxic salty
angry gamers leaving toxic angry reviews
when they're just bad at the game okay
clearly
i'm from hell for you homie fam that
ain't [ __ ] for me
nice i love this ah this is my city i
never actually played that it looks good
the original of course i mean
happiness is worth the pride
hey what's yourself man
nice
good job
wonderful
maybe just don't remake the games there
maybe just don't
is everyone trying to get into the same
driveway nice
another one
there it is
the anatomy makes sense all of a sudden
you know what i was the fool who
wouldn't want to pay a full price for
this game look at that beauty
i'm playing san andreas on ps5 don't
look behind you when first person on the
quad bike it's cursed
i love when this is posted on the
original subreddit too beautiful
gorgeous isn't it the definite edition
this is the definite one that you
definitely want to play
let's go so if you wiggle your car it
gets bigger
is that true oh
oh wow
yes
wait is that real that can't for real
okay i kind of want to play the game now
ah they don't even bother rotating the
burger on the new version that is so
dumb
come on man i know it's not important
who cares if the burger spins but it
just shows an overall lack of quality so
there you go i can't believe all these
toxic gamers are just rating dislike on
this beautiful game how dare they be so
ungrateful there's clearly nothing wrong
with this as shown in this video thanks
for watching if you enjoyed subscribe
for more videos i'll see you guys
tomorrow with another one rufus